how do you look at that being a white
rapper in hip-hop that's a predominantly
black genre
and oftentimes people say you're a guest
how do you take that statement I think
it's true
it is true
and
I agree you if you look at the origin of
where hip-hop came from
and and what was happening in New York
City and what was happening in the Bronx
and the way that black people and people
of color have been treated historically
in America from the jump
um this was a music that was birthed out
of Oppression hip-hop is inclusive so
there's always been an open door to a
certain extent in certain moments it was
a little bit harder to push it open back
in the 90s but I'm a guest yeah M's a
guest doesn't matter how good we get
doesn't matter how great Eminem is we're
guests in the culture
100 percent